once upon a time TV shows weren't even
allowed to show married couples sleeping
in the same bed nowadays you can't go
five minutes without seeing a love scene
on TV but while some love scenes are
truly hot others just amp the cringe
factor up to a million here's a look at
the most Awkward on-screen love scenes
in TV Cougar Town if you're gonna call
show Cougar Town you need to have some
Cougars in it still even though actor
Dan bird is only six years younger than
star Busy Philipps in real life this
tryst felt really creepy that's because
his character is the son of her
characters best friend played by
Courtney Cox who walks in on them
together in the shower yeah that's just
gross friends Cox has been on the other
side of an awkward love scene too on
friends she played Monica who in a sixth
season episode set out to prove that
being sick isn't gonna stop her from
having a good time she aggressively
attempts to seduce her reluctant
boyfriend Chandler finally getting her
way by using the age-old aphrodisiac
Vicks VapoRub oh yeah
work like a cha and nope that's 70 sho
walking in on your parents is a classic
sitcom joke these days
in that 70 shell for instance Eric comes
home when he shouldn't have and walks
right into his parents room while
they're going at it like a couple of
teenager at 'its viewers don't see kitty
and red in the buff as the scene unfolds
entirely in the form of Eric's horrified
and Confused face two and a Half Men
Charlie seemed to be the brother who got
the fun and glamorous adult fun times on
Two and a Half Men while Alan got the
difficult ones like the time he ate just
a few too many oysters right as he and
girlfriend Lindsay were about to get it
on during a romantic hotel getaway talk
about a mood killer Big Bang Theory it's
not just real love that can go horribly
wrong
love over the Internet can glitch out to
just ask Big Bang Theory's Leonard who
attempted to use his best seductive
voice during an erotic FaceTime with his
girlfriend in India one problem her
parents were in the room off screen and
heard every bit of it whoops Felicity
the college set series Felicity was
about a bunch of young adults trying
their hardest to grow up and often
failing in the first season the virginal
Felicity returns to school after winter
break and tells her sort of boyfriend
Knoll that she thinks they should make
love for the first time leading up to
the big night Felicity gets very type-a
responsible and practical about the
whole thing which includes buying books
about love and determining the right
form of birth control but when it
actually happens it doesn't quite happen
thanks to one very poorly placed candle
Seinfeld in a classic episode of
Seinfeld Jerry brags that Elaine never
had to fake it with him to which she
responds that well she did Jerry begs
her for 30 minutes to prove himself
which she declines because it will ruin
their friendship when Jerry continues
moping she then changes her mind for the
sake of saving the friendship it
concludes with a shot of Jerry and
Elaine lying in bed with Elaine reading
a magazine and Jerry looking
oh well How I Met Your Mother
on the hit series How I Met Your Mother
Barney's brother points out the many
similarities between Barney's new
girlfriend Nora and their mom
the thought gets into Barney's head too
and before long he keeps seeing his
mother when he looks at Nora Nora
eventually initiates things with Barney
on the couch but he and the audience
sees mom lying on top of him there's
really only one appropriate reaction to
that god oh god please no no thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]